Speaker 1: Failed gubernatorial candidate
Carry Lake and bonkers election denier is
clearly planning to run for Senate or it's
very likely that she's going to run for Senate
in Arizona.
I have a moment from a recent interview for
you here where she gets asked about her 2024
plans and we've seen her showing up in Iowa.
So some people are thinking, is she wanting
to be Trump's vice presidential running mate,
which I'm sure she would want that as well.
But it does seem her eyes are set on a Senate
run.
Take a look at this bulk.
Speaker 5: Wow.
Speaker 3: You thought it was gonna be easy.
Speaker 5: I thought it was.
Speaker 3: Okay.
We're friends.
Speaker 5: Well, then I'll just be really
honest.
Speaker 3: Which one do you want to tackle?
The Senate or the VP one first.
Speaker 5: Let's hit them both head on.
Okay.
Obviously, my case is is the most important
thing.
Of course.
But you're asking if things don't go well,
if the judicial system is much more corrupt
than we than we think it is.
What happens?
Yeah.
I am seriously considering a run for Senate.
Yes, absolutely.
Because just because they saw an election
were so dangerous to them.
I'm so dangerous to the status quo in this
rotten swamp that they're willing to steal
the election to stop me and our movement.
I'm not letting them get away with that.
We're not going away.
Speaker 1: And so you're dangerous to democracy.
Not dangerous to the status quo and kind of
a good way of mixing things up and improving
it.
We'll watch a little bit more from this, but
there.
When politicians say I'm seriously considering
it, that means it's definitely happening.
Because normally the answer is, oh, I don't
know.
I'm I'm focused on only this.
I am not even thinking about that.
And still they likely are considering if you
say I'm really seriously considering it, that's
definitely the plan that you're working on.
And again, she's also been seemingly auditioning
to be Trump's vice presidential running mate.
So maybe she's waiting to see how that's going
to work out.
But the bad part about this and we'll talk
about another important angle on this after
the second clip I'm going to show you.
But first is because Kirsten, cinema seems
to also be running for reelection as an independent,
but is still left of center.
And Ruben Gallego is in the race if Kerry
does get into the race or another Republican,
but especially someone as dangerous as Kerry,
like just with her election to dying and conspiracy
theories and all of that.
She'll have a better shot because of the independent
Democratic split situation in my mind and
how that could mix things up.
So it'll definitely be something we watch
closely.
But continuing with this interview.
Speaker 5: I am seriously considering a run
for Senate.
All the polling shows that I would win not
just the primary.
The polling is showing I would beat both Kyrsten
Sinema and this socialist guy that's running
all the other Democrats jumping Gallego.
Speaker 3: And so what are you worried, though,
Kerry?
Because we know.
Speaker 1: And it depends on the poll that
you look at.
Ruben Gallego has been leading both Catholic
and Christian cinema in polling recently.
Speaker 3: The voter rolls are corrupt.
We know that these mail in ballots can be
corrupted.
All these issues with Maricopa County specifically.
And obviously, if you run for that Senate
seat, just like gubernatorial, that's the
entire state, not like a congressional district
of only seven or 8000 folks, You're running
for the whole state.
How do we guarantee do we have new stuff in
place?
Will you have new poll watchers to make sure
it's not screwed?
Speaker 5: This is why I'm fighting it right
now.
I want to I want to get our elections straightened
out and I want them to be honest.
And that's why I'm fighting so hard right
now.
We'll take it to the Supreme Court if we.
Speaker 1: Okay.
And then she's talking about her election
lawsuit.
But that is representative of this strange,
logical, uh, you know, the the gymnastics
that has to be done mentally for supporters
of people like Trump and Kelly, because now
Trump is and Kerry may soon be running another
campaign.
And convincing their followers that, yeah,
as I keep saying, the last election was stolen.
And nothing significantly has changed within
my conspiracy theory about what is going on.
All the corruption.
But I could win this one.
In the case of Trump, the Dominion voting
system flipping thousands and thousands of
votes from Trump to Biden.
But that's not going to happen in 2024.
I don't understand as a follower, how you
don't just disengage and not understand how
your vote is going to make a difference.
If the Democrats have this big conspiracy
where they can steal elections, as Carrie
Lake says and Trump says.
But the other notable part about a possible
2024 Kerry like Senate run, is how the election
in nine will play into that.
Because for the general electorate, obviously,
I just talked about how it plays into her
own voters thinking it was stolen, but also
thinking she could win this one.
But then how it plays into her ability to
win the general.
Election because we saw that not work.
In 2022.
Now, as I said, with the unique landscape,
with the independent, that can mix things
up.
But generally, the mid-term is definitely
highlighted this.
The American electorate wholesale is not on
board with the election.
And so for her to lean into that so much and
for her 2024 campaign to be similar to Trump's,
which is, hey, I lost that last election,
but I don't think that I did is a strange
strategy.
And it really is.
As you can tell in every interview she does
and all of her public statements, it's what
she's obsessed with.
She can't accept that she just lost.
So she has to have, like Trump, the conspiracy
theories.
And so when that's a part of a campaign, I
just don't see how that works.
It could, unfortunately, but reasonably, I
don't see how that could work.
To say I should be elected because I falsely
believe I lost the last or I actually won
the last time when I lost.
But that's the moment that we're in in American
politics.
Make sure you subscribe to the Dave Pacman
Show YouTube channel and my YouTube channel
at Luke Beazley on YouTube.
So great guest hosting today.
Much love to you all.
I'll see you soon.